TRYING TO COVER UP THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THEN THERE'SP THIS.
WHY DID MUELLER LEAVE IT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO DECIDE
OBSTRUCTION?
RATHER THAN WAIT A A COUPLE OF
YEARS ANDST SEE WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT WINS REELECTION AND IF
HE DOESN'T, THEN INDICT HIM IN
2020.
NOTICE HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
THE ANSWER IS, THERE WERE NO
CRIMES.
HE HAD NO CASE.
THERE WAS NO PROBABLE CAUSE.
AND YET BY MUELLER WRITING
VOLUME TWO AND GIVING HIS LITTLE
SPIEL TODAY -- AND HE WAS VERY
FEEBLE.
I'M SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS NOT A MAN WHO WOULD DO
WELL UNDER SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE,
TEN HOURS OF QUESTIONING WITH
REPUBLICANS HONING IN ON SO MANY
ISSUES.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHY DID HE
DO THIS TODAY?
WHY DID HE DO THIS TODAY?
LISTEN TO THE DEMOCRATS TODAY.
THEY ARE THRILLED WITH THIS MAN.
THEY WERE NOT THRILLED WITH HIM
YESTERDAY.
THEY ARE W THRILLED WITH HIM TOD
THEY ARE W THRILLED WITH HIM TOY
BECAUSE THEY THINK -- AND THEY
ARE WRONG -- THAT HE DELIVERED
THEM NEW INFORMATION.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE MEDIA IS
THIS: I JUST WENT THROUGH SOME
BASIC LAWYERING.
AS HE MENTIONED THAT HE COULD
HAVE CHARGED BECAUSE HE HAS
PROBABLE CAUSE?
NO, HE DIDN'T.
WHO ARE THESE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE, THAT THEY
ARE INTERESTED IN?
THERE WEREN'T ANY, THERE WASN'T
ANY.
WHY DIDN'T HE WAIT A COUPLE OF
YEARS?
WHAT IS HE IN A HURRY FOR?
NOBODY BOTHERS HIM.
HE IS NOBLE, HE'S BETTER THAN